there are paper airplanes and then there
are John Collins's paper airplanes
Marvel's that return to sender sideways
and somersaulting a plane that seems to
fly like a bat and one that soars and
soars I'm John Collins the paper
airplane guy for decades Collins has
been perfecting the art and science of
the paper airplane
I just love figuring out how things fly
there's a you know a number of things
you can watch fly when your kid insects
the birds to full-size planes and they
only fly using slightly different
mechanisms and that was just endlessly
fascinating for me and the idea that you
could fold a flying machine from this
really modest resource a piece of papers
people are throwing it away by the tons
you could grab a piece and reuse that
and make a flying machine out of it
after going about as far as I could go
folding planes I decided I need to study
this other field this art called origami
so I worked on that for about 10 years
learning what was to learn there and
then took all those folding techniques
back to paper airplanes with an idea
toward making you know a set of really
great high performance planes if all you
had was paper you could just make some
high-performance flying machines Collins
makes one of the most high-performance
paper airplanes six years ago he set a
new world record for distance by
designing and folding this astounding
long distance glider it was thrown by
quarterback Joe au but there it is there
it is we are all over that one that's
gonna do it get up there get up there
get up there get up there get up there
[Applause]
so we broke the distance record the old
record was 207 feet four inches and we
threw two hundred 26 feet ten inches we
were the first glider to break that 200
foot barrier to break out and set a
distance record it had all been done
with ballistic dart swings about this
wide our plane has really wide wings the
old style you'd throw in a 45 degree
angle and it would just crash it at the
finish line just a parabolic arc my
plane takes nine seconds to do that and
so it's a real difference in approach
you know if you watch the world record
throw it gets launched level climbs on
its own and then really flares and flies
for that last third so it's it's a real
flying machine opposed to as opposed to
the ballistic dart that could just roll
any direction just crash Colin stop by
the wired studio to fly the distance
glider and some of the other planes in
his new book the world record paper
airplane and to demonstrate how a humble
piece of paper can become any number of
thrilling toys in minutes people people
always think I have top-secret paper
here so all my planes are designed with
just regular old eight-and-a-half by 11
25 paper in line you know the basics of
the basics no accurate folding line up
the edges correctly be really precise
about what you're doing and then overall
symmetry is super important this is
gonna be the world record plan it's
named after my wife it's named Suzanne
starts out with a couple of diagonal
folds a short side of the paper up we're
gonna take the top of the page and put
it against the side of the page we're
gonna make two diagonal folds here so
let's practice on the other side shall
we
we're gonna move this corner over line
up over the top corner and then swing
this guy into position and as a double
check I can see where my other diagonal
is ending and sweep down that way now
I've got nice tight corners everywhere
nice sharp creases we're going to take
the right-hand edge just from the
creased corner down to where this crease
meets the edge of the page and we're
going to lay it against the diagonal
fold we're gonna take this creased
corner and bring it just to the end of
this crease right here fold the top down
and now you'll see those diagonal folds
on the other side what you want to do is
line up the diagonal folds the top layer
of the diagonal with the very
lair of the diagonal on both sides and
that's how you know you're hitting the
center of the X dead center so let's
follow the crease on both sides what I
find to be the easiest way to do it is
to follow the creases on this side but
if you can see them clearly on the other
side and that works for you go ahead and
use it flipped over we're going to take
this flap right here and fold it up over
those two corners and when we do the
next move to fold the plane in half the
whole thing will be locked together so
let's fold from the top all the way down
to the center of this edge to fold the
plane in half you can flip it over and
make sure the rear corners and the nose
are perfect the center corners don't
worry so much about don't spend a lot of
time trying to line those guys up the
rear corners and make sure you're
hitting the nose cleanly now here's the
pro way to do it make sure wings a
little bit wider makes the plane a more
efficient glider if you start here and
don't make the crease but see you've got
a little triangle that you can see here
made up from this raw edge and the back
of the fuselage if you keep pulling the
wing down just until that triangle
disappears that is a much better place
to make the wing crease it makes the
tail much broader gives you much better
lifting characteristics so let's make
the other wing match that should be an
easy task and the most important thing
to remember is that every flight is a
test flight you're now a pilot you're
seeing if this thing flies you're making
adjustments to it most people think they
can't fold a good plane but the reality
is they just have it adjusted a good
plane so the first thing we do the wings
are drooping like that we're gonna give
it what's called positive dihedral angle
now the hero angle that's just fancy
words for the angle the wings are stuck
to the body of the plane and what that
does when you hold on to it where all
the layers lock and just lift the
leading edge of the wings now you've got
some upward sweep there and what that
does is put the lifting surface up over
where all the way it is so if the plane
is flying along and it gets rocked to
one side just like a pendulum the weight
swings back underneath the wings and
that's called dead-stick stability the
other thing we're going to do aside from
positive dihedral angle is give the rear
corners just a little upward bend
a lot and don't make a crease just make
a bend you can always undo the bend
flatten it out or add a little bit more
and with all gliders you're constantly
trading height for speed what do I mean
by that so if the centre of gravity and
the center of lift were perfectly lined
up your plane would fly nice and
straight and drag would constantly be
slowing it down until it just fell out
of the sky a stall is caused by too slow
an air speed or too high an angle of
attack that's where the wings are tilted
up with regard to the direction of air
flow so if you have a plane that's
flying straight and level and it's
perfectly balanced eventually drag will
slow it till it falls out of the sky so
how do you fix that with a glider with a
powered plane you just hit the gas right
super simple with a glider what you need
to do is engineer in the center of
gravity a little bit in front of the
center of lift the center of gravity is
the center of spin you can find that on
any paper airplane simply by spinning it
you can see right where the center of
gravity is on that plane it's right here
you just watched it spin the center of
spin is the center of gravity we've got
all this lifting surface behind the
center of gravity so now the plane is
going to fly along the lift is back here
it pitches the nose downward as the
planes going forward what does that do
that allows me to gain speed the plane
is being slowed now I'm pointing the
nose at the ground gaining speed which
is good but now I keep dating speed at
9.8 meters per second per second it's
gonna crash into the ground really hard
so I bend in some elevator back here and
the air goes down the top of the wing
hits that bend gets kicked up which
pushes the tail down which lifts the
nose and voila now the nose is level
again so enough up elevator so at the
right speed the plane noses up enough to
just achieve horizontal stability that's
the whole trick with any glider you're
constantly balancing that center of
gravity center of lift and a little bit
of up elevator to get that perfect
flight but not all of Colin's planes are
about distance some like his boomerang
models are fun and smaller spaces thanks
to some interesting aerodynamics the
boomerang plane this one is great
because it'll circle either direction
and it loops the basic trick with this
one is that the center of gravity is
very very close to the center of lift so
all you need to do is add just a tiny
bit of up elevator here and the other
thing has to do with something we talked
about before which
dihedral angle now most good planes have
positive dihedral which gets the plane
to rock back to neutral
but the boomerang plane the wings are
drooping so if I throw it leaned over it
does not self-correct it stays leaned
over then you have to imagine what a
climb is gonna look like leaned over
it's gonna look like a circle that way
or a circle that way or a loop it's all
the same trick and then boomerang too so
this plane is made to fly out flip over
and fly back upside down it accomplishes
that because it's really a failure of a
paper airplane this I was trying to do
landing gears on the boomerang one and
that's these guys here and that puts too
many layers toward the rear so this is
extremely tail heavy and it does that
crazy tip stall out there so flying out
positive dihedral on the way out after
the stall positive dihedral angle on the
way back and then it's you know toying
again with all the adjusting I'm bending
the leading edge down a little bit so
when it's upside down
I'm getting a little scoop up to help
the nose come back and then I've got a
little bit of elevator here to help
magnify that crazy tip stall out there
so it's this dance between what you do
at the front and the back to get it to
fly perfectly both ways this is a really
fun plane called a batplane it was
actually a design mistake it's not what
I was going to make but it ended up
doing something really weird when I
threw it for the first time the wings
were oscillate when you throw it so
which actually happening is the plane is
going through a rapid series of stalls
it's a little bit tail heavy and I've
got too much up elevator here so it
flies in stalls and as as the body is
flexible the wings flex upward at the
top of the stall no more pressure the
winds relaxed
it applies in stalls I I wish I could
tell you the secret sauce to coming up
with a new great paper airplane and I
have a couple of approaches and
sometimes they overlap and sometimes
they don't sometimes it's a design
approach like I want to do a plane that
it's landing gear where I want to do a
plane that has a tunnel in the nose or
one that has a small wing in front and
so you bring sort of the origami skills
to bear on that and so you have to put
in the time and that's what I would say
you know to learn and compete with a
plane even as simple as this you do have
to put the time in to get to know the
material
and figure out how it works obviously
what it does exactly what you wants it's
really kind of a cool feeling that
you've made this really great flying
machine out of just minimal materials
and it really doesn't matter if you
don't get it back in some cases it's you
know it's the joy of that flight yeah
I'm a kid at heart I am a four year old
or five year old once again watching
their plane just fly out of sight and
you know having a moment it's pretty fun
[Music]